the partial government shutdown appears
to be almost over President Trump
announced a three-week deal this
afternoon Congress is already at this
hour working on legislation passing both
chambers we have thoughts team coverage
tonight Mike Emanuel on Capitol Hill to
tell us where the funding process is at
this very moment but we start with chief
White House correspondent John Roberts
and the president pulling the plug after
five full weeks of the shutdown with no
money for his border wall good evening
John Brett good evening to you reaction
from Republicans to the president's deal
is mixed some are applauding the move
others believe the president caved but
the bottom line tonight the president
comes away from the shutdown with little
more than he had going into it political
pressure that had been building for
weeks hit the breaking point this
morning when federal workers missed his
second paycheck and LaGuardia Airport
halted flights because of an air-traffic
control shortage within hours President
truck was in the Rose Garden announcing
the government would soon be fully open
again albeit temporarily in a short
while I will sign a bill to open our
government for three weeks until
February 15th I will make sure that all
employees receive their back pay very
quickly or as soon as possible will
happen fast negotiations between the
president and congressional leadership
kicked into high gear yesterday but
after insisting that any deal to reopen
government had to include money for a
border wall the one the president took
gave him nothing except a pledge from
Democrats to try to reach an agreement
President has agreed to our request to
open the government and then debate
border security the White House insists
it has strong signals from large numbers
of Democrats that they are willing to
give some funding for a boarder barrier
likely not 5.7 billion but the House
Speaker is on record is saying residents
getting nothing had been very clear on
the wall President Trump made it clear
if he doesn't get what he wants in the
next three weeks the nation could be
right back where we started if we don't
get a fair deal from Congress the
government will either shut
On February 15th again or I would use
the powers afforded to me under the laws
and the Constitution of the United
States to address this emergency the
Office of Management and Budget has
identified billions of dollars that
could be redirected toward construction
of a wall but an emergency declaration
would be immediately challenged in the
courts leaving the president with no
options and Democrats today warned him
against shutting down the government
again the American people do not like it
when you throw a wrench into the into
the lives of government workers over an
unrelated political dispute hopefully
now the president has learned his lesson
negotiations over border security will
fall to a bipartisan conference
committee whose mandate is to find
possible compromise over the next 21
days I expect that both Democrats and
Republicans will operate in good faith
this is an opportunity for all parties
to work together for the benefit of our
whole beautiful wonderful nation but the
Democratic leadership couldn't help but
tweak president Trump saying he tried
but failed to get Democrats to crack and
that in Nancy Pelosi he has more than
met his match no one should ever
underestimate the speaker as Donald
Trump has learned the deal that
President Trump accepted today is
identical to one that South Carolina
Senator Lindsey Graham floated two weeks
ago a deal that back then the president
politely rejected insisting he had to
have money in any kind of spending bill
for a border wall a lot changed in two
weeks Brett that's right John thanks